[Music]
you know mostly I remember scenes of
things I mean I remember locations and I
remember taking tours around Saltzburg
which was super fun because it was
instead of school I didn't really have
to be in school but we had a great on
set teacher who you actually didn't have
to spend time with but I wanted to and
we took all kinds of fun field trips all
over Salzburg and I just remember a lot
of different kind of kaleidoscopic
things that a little kid would remember
it also seems timeless because it's set
in a time period so no matter when you
look at it it's that time period it
doesn't you know it's not like something
filmed - maybe in 1960 that was
contemporary and then goes out of date
so it's it's an eternal piece that that
families share with their children and
then it gets passed to the next
generation and the kids seem to be as
into it as their parents or their
grandparents in the casting they had
actually started rehearsals without
listo and I just came in my mother had
an agent and she said is one of your
daughters over 16 looks over 18 looked
16 and can sing and dance and act and
she said well shermian looks quite young
for her age and I went in and I read the
script there was no one else there so I
didn't have a chance to be nervous and I
read the script and I sang the song and
then I danced which I had danced all my
life and I got the part I was a natural
mimic it was Gary I mean I I just kind I
could do that Japanese song oh we were
talking about that in the book that
there was some song that was a big
Kentucky in like 1960 whatever it wasn't
the whole thing in Japanese so I mean
yeah I was in actual mimics so I picked
everything it was a little bit of a
klutz cuz I was near said an undiagnosed
myopic the 16 going on 17 dance that was
the last thing filmed on the sound of
music and I went through the glass on my
first jump on the bench because the
wardrobe department had forgotten to put
the rubber on the soles of my shoes and
Robert Wise I'll never forget he looked
white because everything else was done
and he didn't know how he would finish
it and so they wrapped my ankle and they
gave me what they said was a vitamin b12
shot
[Laughter]
but I didn't feel any pain for the next
three days and since I was older and I
read judy garland's biography that was
still in the time of the studio doctor
and I don't think I was given a vitamin
b12 shot at first I was always
recognized but now people will look at
me and they'll say didn't we go to high
school together